in 2009 the year before I created Vsauce
a company asked me to pitch them a show
about food my friend Justin and I put
together a pilot for a show and this is
literally what we submitted how long
does it take you to make a peanut butter
and banana sandwich 1 minute screw you
less than a minute I'm not going to
spend more than a second making my
sandwich this is food
[Music]
Smashers
this is food
Smashers shockingly food Smashers was
never made um instead the company said
uh okay
look never do food Smashers but could
you make us a YouTube channel about
video games and call it video game
nation and I said yeah whatever fine I I
would love to do that and so I made the
channel about video games but I didn't
like the name video game Nation so I
called it
Vsauce and here we are today